Dodi's are super uncomfortable I feel
very propped up and like like I run I've
never worn heels before high heels any
type of heel stiletto shoe I think I may
have tried on my mom's heels like once
as a kid I have pretty nice legs not
trying to brag so I think I can do
pretty well at this
my ankles should be strong enough to
handle it but there's a lot of weight on
this body on the upper part so we'll say
I think this is going to set so today
I'm going to be giving the guys
different situations that happen in real
life when women walk in heels increasing
the speed and decreasing the speed on a
treadmill I think if they stay balanced
and they stand up straight
they got this all right so let's walk a
mile in heels so here are your wonderful
pink heel please come to like a 1
centimeter long point and I have to put
all my weight on that look at these
boats they're huge I love you all
you're my best friend right now should I
just try going on the treadmill 3 2 1
and we're off all right all right 2
miles per hour well I must say that
these do make my legs look really nice
does it have to do with how I situate my
butt I'm getting used to it it's a
little painful
ok balls of my feet are on fire already
I just feel like it's treacherous like
at any moment I could just tip over no
no no that one
I'm a confident lady with hot calves
[Music]
walk away I made a mistake what I like
it better fast the pain is in shorter
bursts tell him to bring his ass over
here I don't walk tumors underwear these
are socks I probably a little bit more
tolerable I feel like there's something
about having to maintain this posture
that is wearing me out I don't
understand how anyone makes this look
elegant 20 minutes half a mile now
you're halfway through you've made it to
the club your favorite DJ is playing
your favorite
wait I'm running to the dance floor cuz
this what's going on I can't believe
this is just regular for some people
trying to leave my my arms my hands off
of the armholes I'm also trying not to
bust my ass it's crazy how loud your
footsteps are winter wearing heels
Christie Christie wait Rachel Rachel
where are you going come back I need
your help
you're outside with your friends a car
passes by and a guy yells honey
no I just thought my shoe just throw the
shoe run from the creeper I feel like
other people keep not my night get back
here
first there was the uber driver now
there's some guy yelling at me I mean I
know I'm fine but I'm perforating you
have just been a Big Mac and now you're
walking home still a little tipsy oh I
do feel tipsy is this after the club now
how I should feel like I want to cry and
go home and eat a pie to Ben and Jerry's
gonna run that last little bit no no I'm
just gonna walk at this one mile look
come here
bench you're my friend I thought I'd get
the hang of it and it wouldn't hurt so
much but it just kept hurting the whole
time I feel like anyone who can survive
a night in heels is a warrior I don't
know how you ladies do it childbirth
wearing heels dealing with men I am
never wearing these again respect
[Music]
Wow
[Music]